Cooper: No. Don't let me leave, Murph!
Ah!
No! No! No! [sobbing]
Narrator: This is the
moment when the big twist
in "Interstellar" is revealed:
that Cooper was the ghost
interacting with Murph's bookshelf
from the beginning of the film.
This is the moment we find out
the big twist in "The Prestige":
that Angier cloned and
killed himself every night
to achieve his magic trick.
And this is the moment we find out
the big twist in "Following":
that Bill is being framed for murder.
All these scenes have something in common,
and not just that they're
directed by Christopher Nolan.
We see each of these scenes
multiple times in their movies.
So, how are scenes we've already watched
still able to deliver such a big twist?
The secret lies in
Nolan's use of recurrence.
Nolan uses the idea of
recurrence in his films
in a myriad of ways.
In "Inception," recurrence is featured
as a main component of the plot,
creating dreams within dreams.
In "The Prestige," Nolan
explores recurrence as a motif.
The film features twins and clones,
diaries within diaries,
and the main characters repeatedly
sabotaging each other's magic tricks.
And in "Memento,"
the very structure of
the film is recursive,
as the film constantly alternates
between scenes from the past
and scenes from the present.
Put simply, recurrence
is continued repetition.
However, one of Nolan's
greatest uses of recurrence
is how he employs it
to deliver twists at the end of his films.
A simple first example to
help wrap your head around
how Nolan uses recurrence to
pull off his twist endings
comes from a scene in "The Prestige"
that Nolan replays three
times throughout the film.
At 47 seconds into the film,
we see a bunch of top hats in a forest.
When the scene cuts away from
the hats, it's confusing.
We don't see the hats again
for another hour and 25 minutes,
when we learn that the
hats have been duplicated
by Tesla's machine.
This time, the scene
makes a little more sense.
However, the real significance of the hats
isn't revealed until Nolan shows us
the top hats once again
right before his final reveal.
Angier achieves his magic trick
by cloning himself every night
using the same Tesla machine
that duplicated the top hats,
ultimately drowning each of his clones.
So we see the scene three times,
and our experience of it the third time
is significantly different
than when we saw it the first time.
Suddenly, the perplexing
scene from the opening
now makes sense because
of all of the context
that we get throughout the movie.
And even though the movie presents us
with everything we need to figure out
the significance of the opening image...
Angier: Well, which one is mine?
Tesla: They're all you hats, Mr. Angier.
Narrator: We don't tend to
apply what we've learned
until the scene plays again.
Now, one could argue that the scene
is just a simple flashback,
but it's actually more than that.
While many films and
filmmakers use flashbacks
and nonlinear storytelling,
what makes Nolan's style distinct
is that he doesn't flash
back just once in his films.
Instead of structuring his nonlinear films
to have distinct sections
that are out of order
chronologically, like "Pulp Fiction,"
the nonlinear structures of Nolan's films
constantly flash back and forth
between distinct timelines,
adding more and more
context to each timeline
with each recurrence,
until, ultimately, everything makes sense.
Now, using recurrence does not at all
make a film inherently better,
but it does happen to be an
extremely helpful technique
when trying to create a twist ending.
Even among movies with twist endings,
Nolan's use of recurrence
sets his films apart from the rest.
For example, in the film
"The Usual Suspects,"
there is certainly a twist
at the end of the film,
but it's a one-and-done reveal.
The seemingly meek Verbal
was lying throughout the film
and is actually the fabled
crime boss Keyser Söze.
So while it's an
entertaining twist ending,
the film purposefully
misleads the audience
throughout the majority of the film,
and there are very few
clues placed throughout
that lead the audience to the
truth about Verbal's identity.
However, in Nolan's films,
the audience is almost always
given the opportunity to solve the mystery
through recursively
presented clues and scenes
that are shown over and over again.
Take, for example, the
opening shot of "Inception,"
where a haggard Cobb washes up on a beach
and talks with an old man.
This scene is revisited
again at the end of the film,
now that the audience
understands the context
and realizes what's going on:
that this beach is limbo and
that Cobb has traveled there
in order to save Saito, the old man.
Nolan even shows a very similar
scene of Cobb and Ariadne
washing up on the beaches of Cobb's limbo,
but he doesn't leave enough
time for the audience to process
the significance of
washing up on the beach
and its connection to the short scene
that happened two hours before.
Nolan is constantly
presenting the audience
with all of the answers
throughout his films,
but we just don't quite
know what to look for
until he shows us right at the very end.
The fact that Nolan is able to repeatedly
show the audience the truth
without them realizing what's happening
is what makes his films so iconic.
While the twist of "The Usual Suspects"
is like telling you that the
duck you've been staring at
is actually a rabbit,
the twists in Nolan's films
are more like a hidden puzzle.
There's a colorful image or a scene
that doesn't make sense when
you look at it the first time;
however, when Nolan finally
gives the audience the key
and you revisit the image,
you can see things clearly.
This is why revisiting Nolan's
scenes are such a twist.
The answer has been there the whole time,
hiding in plain sight.
Even Nolan's films that don't have
traditional twist endings
have recursive elements.
For example, in "Dunkirk,"
he shows the same scene from
several different perspectives,
which results in a miniature twist.
While initially it appears
that the pilot, Collins,
is fine after being shot
down by an enemy plane,
waving to the other pilot,
when Nolan later cuts to Collins'
perspective of the event,
it turns out that he's actually not OK.
His waving is actually him
struggling to open his cockpit
while he slowly begins to drown.
While this is one of
the most basic examples
of Nolan's recurrence,
it shows how such a simple
tool can be so powerful.
Luckily, knowing how Nolan works
won't necessarily ruin your
experience watching his films.
As Cutter famously says at
the end of "The Prestige"...